die meist gestellte Frage in meine
Richtung von
Mittelständlern Handwerkern ist immer
die warum machen die das in der
Bundesregierung so warum treffen die
Entscheidungen die uns so viel Schaden
zubereiten und ich finde Politik gute
Politik beginnt immer mein Betrachten
der Wirklichkeit und das was wir im
Moment erleben hat nichts mit der
Wirklichkeit zu tun es ist eine es sind
Entscheidungen die Vorbeigehen an dem
was unternehmen was die Menschen in
diesem Land tatsächlich brauchen und das
ist der Vorwurf den ich auch der
Bundesregierung mache und damit auch den
Grünen Herr Marquardt es gab mehrere
Fragen warum machen sie das so kommt die
Frage aus dem Wahlkreis von Frau Schimke
und wir fahren heute fragt sie ganz
offen ja ja Transformation ist ja gut
und schön aber welche Industrie wird es
schön meinen sie dann in Zukunft na gut
wir haben jetzt kurzfristig einfach das
Problem dass wir über Jahre uns abhängig
gemacht haben von einem Partner der
überhaupt kein Partner war ich glaube da
sind wir uns einig und da müssen wir mit
einer Situation umgehen in der es ja
nicht weltweit einen gasmangel gibt mit
einmal sondern in der wir eben einfach
nicht die Infrastruktur haben um das Gas
kurzfristig von woanders her zu bekommen
was dann eben auch die Preise so in die
Höhe treibt der Grund für die hohen
Preis ist ja nicht Robert Habeck
Friedrich Merz Christian Lindner oder so
soll das Wladimir Putin und
das ist sind früher regiert dann die uns
in dieser Abhängigkeit geführt haben da
können wir ein Haken dran machen und das
geht nicht oder kaum auf Ihr Konto auf
das grüne Konto jetzt war aber in der
Situation wo wir dringend die Gaspreise
runterdrücken müssen genau in der
Industrie dafür sorgen müssen dass
Energie bezahlbar ist dass wir bei
Metzgermeister in Bamberg dafür sorgen
müssen dass Energie bezahlbar ist und
die Menschen fragen sich auch in
Wahlkreis von Frau Schinkel tun sie
alles dafür damit der Preis dann das tun
also ehrlicherweise glaube ich dass das
also was zu lange gedauert hat ist die
Entscheidung wirklich viel Geld in die
Hand zu nehmen um kurzfristig die
Gaspreise so zu deckeln dass also
eigentlich rentabel Unternehmen dann mit
einmal nicht mehr weiter produzieren
können dass sie eigentlich einmal vor
Existenzängsten stehen obwohl wir jetzt
eigentlich eine Brücke bauen können mit
Geld das in die Hand zu nehmen ist sich
richtig die 200 Milliarden jetzt aber
auch schon die anderen entlastungspakete
und was wir dann jetzt schaffen müssen
ist das in der Tat wir können das nicht
jedes Jahr machen wäre ich
Volkswirtschaft soll das bezahlen
sondern dass wir dann eben die Gaspreise
wieder auf man kann sagen natürliche Art
und Weise so gering halten dass ich
bestimmte Modelle von Industrie auch so
darauf einstellen kann aber Herr
Marquardt dann ist doch BASF schon raus
dann haben die hier die Arbeitsplätze
schon gestrichen dann ist der
Metzgereibetrieb in Bamberg halt schon
dicht also ich sage ja mein Nachbar
heißt der beinahe wie ich aber trotzdem
bin ich der Meinung die Grünen sind die
Pfarre sehr der deutschen Politik die
sagen wir machen alles besser die setzen
sich moralisch aufs hohe Ross
und sie schaffen den Kernenergie ab wir
fahren heute hat gesagt 15 April das ist
das Samstag nach Ostern da werden die
Kern entkraftwerk ganz stillgelegt ist
dann die Energiekrise vorbei natürlich
nicht die anderen Nationen gehen rein
wir gehen raus sind auch das Thema
Fracking also wir sind pharisäerhaft und
sagen wir wollen keine Kernkraft auf wir
kaufen Sie im Rest von Europa wir wollen
kein Fracking weil wir das für ekelhaft
halten kaufen aber teures anderswo
gefrecktes Gas ich benutze mal ist es
Wort um uns damit zu ändern das ist
unmöglich ja und wir vertreiben die
deutsche Industrie aus dem Land und an
jedem Arbeitsplatz hängt ja auch eine
Familie dann muss er sich mal vorstellen
das geht tief in den deutschen Wohlstand
hinein weil wir da nicht eine Bremse
ziehen und sie machen alles mit in
Berlin mit der FDP
sie lassen den laufen also ich bin
natürlich ein unabhängiger freier
liberaler und bin nicht Mitglied dieser
Ampel mir tut der Christian Lindner leid
weil er mit diesen zwei
eigentumsfeindlichen Parteien dass ich
rumquälen muss ja ein paar Sachen
durchgesetzt wir wollten diese Ampel
nicht das ist aber kein Menschen
mitgemacht jetzt ist er Finanzminister
ganz dummerweise und ich glaube keiner
mit dem man richtig Mitleid haben muss
er trägt jeder Entscheidung mit ja
immerhin schafft er jetzt die kalte
Progression ab weil viele BürgerInnen
Atomkraftwerken 50 april ist es
Markwort macht für die FDP mal eben
schlanken Fuß und sagt aber es ist das
kleine Verdienst der FDP das wenigstens
die Verlängerung bis auf diesen Sonntag
nach Ostern durchgesetzt wurde das ist
mir überhaupt nicht genug groß aber ohne
Design sich wirklich um das Land zu
sorgen aber Sorgen
im Moment erleben in Deutschland ist
doch ein hochgradiger politischer
Skandal
Minister Habeck hat in seinem Hause
zusammen mit Ministerin Lemke den
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke prüfen
lassen das Ergebnis wurde vorweggenommen
ich finde das das ist doch das ist doch
da muss doch sofort Konsequenzen gezogen
werden
weil dieser Bundesregierung der ist
nicht länger tragbar er hat gelogen er
und Frau Lemke haben gelogen die expert
wenn es geprüft wird und es wird gar
nicht ernsthaft geprüft sondern es steht
hinten auf der Seite schon ach der
Beschluss wir steigen auch die Grünen
haben wir tausende von Posten besetzt in
den Ämtern hat mit Trittin angefangen
und auch da habe ich halt überall seine
grünen Leute reingetan und ich habe ja
glaube ich in einer springerzeitung
gelesen dass fies sogar die letzten
ökonomisch denkenden von Vernunft
geprägten Beamten im
Wirtschaftsministerium gegen Habeck
votiert haben aber das wurde unterdrückt
noch mal sie spielen nicht Sie
persönlich aber ihre Farbe ihre gelbe
Farbe spielt das ja alles mit in nein
muss ich schon mal sagen ja wir haben es
sehr schwer genug in diesem 1 soweit zu
zwei Spiel die FDP hat dafür gesorgt
dass wenigstens bis 15 April diese drei
Kernkraftwerken weiterlaufen
noch mal anfangen wer ich bin dafür dass
wir noch mal darauf anfangen die Debatte
kommt wieder die brettstäbe müssen
gekauft werden
Marquardt auf die den Vorwurf von
froschschenke die sagt der Minister hat
gelogen der ist nicht tragbar in dieser
Regierung er hat den Beschluss schon
gekannt obwohl es gar nicht geprüft war
es wurde ja geprüft und nun kann man da
das Design dieser Studie sich lange
anschauen und schauen ich habe jetzt
keine ernsthafte Kritik davon von der
wissenschaftlichen Seite mitbekommen ich
habe mitbekommen dass das was die
Kernkraft zu leisten im Stande ist
momentan genutzt wird der Einfluss auf
den Preis ist marginal momentan mit
diesen drei Kernkraftwerke
aber das haben wir doch gesehen
gefroren hat gegen die Preise so runter
das allein das Signal hat die Preise
nach unten bewegt und wir müssen doch
wissen das ist die preiswerteste in der
stromerzeugungsform in Deutschland wenn
Sie die wegnehmen dann schieben sie die
Gaskraftwerke natürlich in der merit
order nach links und dann steigen wir
die Preise explosiv an aber wichtig ist
Energiemanager der jetzt auch nicht der
totale Kernkraft fällt das will ich
schon mal sagen ich finde wir müssen
auch für die Erneuerbaren sorgen aber
man macht sich nicht ehrlich weil sie
müssen sich ja mal anschauen in der Zeit
wo jetzt habe ich dran ist sind jetzt
gerade mal
3000 Megawatt Windenergie angemeldet
worden fürs nächste Jahr obwohl die
Gesetze so entschlackt worden sind und
das Naturschutzgesetz ja wirklich
zerfleddert worden ist
3000 es hat einen Grund warum weil
nämlich mittlerweile auch die Preise für
Windenergie massiv ansteigen die
Materialkosten steigen die Kapitalkosten
steigen ist und jetzt müssen sie mal
sich vorstellen was das bedeutet das
heißt im ganzen nächsten Jahr kommen
7000 Megawatt schlappe Megawatt 7000
Terawattstunden Entschuldigung 7000
Stunden ans Netz das ist ein Fünftel der
Kernenergie die wir am 15 April
abstellen das wird nicht gut gehen das
wird nicht funktionieren und deswegen
muss man sich ehrlich machen und ich
finde das erste was man machen muss ist
auch dann zu denjenigen die einem jetzt
Gas liefern können nicht so arrogant
hinzugehen ich meine er war ein Catan
hat gesagt also ich brauche für sieben
Jahre Gas und dann hat er ihm gesagt nee
wenn wir jetzt ein neues Feld machen und
dann noch ein LNG Terminal bauen dann
brauchen wir dann 20 jahreswetter dem
Scheich gesagt brauche ich das nicht
mehr weil in sieben Jahren wollen wir
aus dem Gas raus weil wir wollen ja
CO2-frei sein das gleiche hat er in
Israel gemacht ja die israelische
Regierung sogar mehr oder weniger
beleidigt immer gesagt hat also wenn das
drei Jahre dauert dann brauche ich nicht
mehr denn dann sind wir sowieso schon
raus dann in Kanada das gleiche da hat
er gesagt nehmen wir mal Wasserstoff das
heißt also
Elefant den haben wir überhaupt gar
nicht gesehen Elefant im Raum ist hier
wir haben in Deutschland Erdgas Vorräte
für 20 bis 40 Jahre und jetzt kommt in
den Wege steht und natürlich jedem im
weg weil er denkt verdammt noch mal ich
weiß auch dass in USA geschludert worden
ist da sind Bohrlöcher gemacht von und
die sind nicht mal hinter verfüllt
worden der Gas das Methan jetzt noch aus
das muss man natürlich anständig machen
wir können es aber anständig machen die
nehmen auch Chemikalien die können heute
schon was machen oder
sagen sie können heute Fracking machen
ohne Chemikalien einmal das muss doch
möglich sein in Deutschland dieses
Tracking Verbot endlich auf diese das
ist wirklich der Ingenieure und
Techniker wird dieses Fracking bei uns
besser machen aber sicher ja aber sicher
ich möchte gerne noch mal sind kleineren
Check machen weil er der ist mit seiner
Farbe der hier regiert also sind sie
überzeugt
ich glaube dass wir beim Tracking
einfach die Situation haben dass das
ähnlich wie die Atomkraft Diskussion
momentan eine totale Scheinlösung ist
also man kann so tun als würde das jetzt
große Probleme lösen die Probleme kann
man aber viel besser einfacher und
günstiger anders lösen also zum einen
mit dem Ausbau der Erneuerbaren wo sie
ja auch sagen sie sind nicht dagegen zum
anderen auch indem wir eben jetzt über
die nächsten Jahre auch schauen wie
können wir unsere gaskapazitäten über
LNG Terminals so gewinnen dass wir dann
auch später den Switch machen können und
auch Wasserstoff setzen können mit
diesem LNG bei mir jeden Tag viele viele
Unternehmen
und dann haben wir jetzt im Winter weil
das hilft nicht aktuell für diesen
Winter also es ist ja so dass wir jetzt
wenn sie über Tracking diskutieren dass
die Diskussion also wir hätten sie jetzt
eine Mehrheit in der Bundesregierung
würden sie mit dem Tracking anfangen
wann würde dieses Fracking Gas und die
würden sie das alles besser angefangen
Waren werden nach der dem Einmarsch der
Russen hätte das nach Aussagen der
Experten die wissen genau wo es liegt
dass wir sein
da wäre das erste Gas gefördert worden
wir werden jetzt im nächsten Jahr diesen
Winter gebe ich ihnen zu wer das
schwierig geworden dafür ist ja auch die
gaspreisbremse aber die Gaspreise Bremse
führt nicht in die Zukunft das heißt
wenn wir angefangen werden hätten wir im
nächsten Winter denn der nächste Winter
kommt bestimmt und dann sind die
gasschlägerlich
dass wenn man nicht von vorne rein auf
die letzte Seite geschrieben hat wie das
Ergebnis dieser Prüfung ist es ernsthaft
geprüft hätte dass jetzt dann genügend
Zeit gewesen wäre um eben an diese
zusätzlichen Gasreserven ranzukommen
also wenn ihr gerade über Fracking oder
vom Kraft über beides reden wir also
einfach erhebliche Bedenken dass das
wirklich eine Art ist mit der Natur so
umzugehen dass am Ende nicht das
Trinkwasser in Gefahr ist dass die
Gegenden in denen das passiert dann mit
einmal also man kann jetzt sagen nein
aber es ist doch so dass in den USA was
passiert
paul-geschichten den Fehler war noch mal
auf einer einfachere Dimension kommen
wir können ja hier keine Windräder bauen
das dauert da gibt es 1000 Probleme aber
ich kenne
ich kenne einen Menschen der möchte sich
Photovoltaik aufs Dach machen zwei Jahre
dauert das Genehmigung antragsfest wenn
die das dem Büro diese kleinbürokratie
abgeschafft werde hätten wir soweit
tausende Leuten die innerhalb von sechs
Wochen
Sonnenenergie hätten und würden damit
den Energiemarkt erleichterten sie aber
immer noch nachts keinen Strom aber das
ist schon
Schritt ist das schon ein großer
Industrie noch nicht retten
möglicherweise nicht mehr den Betrieb
von Den Helder vom das noch einmal ganz
konkret zu machen was haben sie bisher
an Energiekosten gehabt und was haben
sie jetzt im Zuge dieser Energiekrise an
Kosten wir haben immer 2000 Euro
monatlichen Abschlag gehabt jetzt seit
Mai 4500 also mehr als verdoppelt und
zum Ende des Jahres ist unter der
Tarifvertrag Stromvertrag gekündigt
worden
dann wird es noch teurer FIFA das würde
das bedeuten für die Waren die sie
anbieten also zum Beispiel
Leberkässemmel
Spaß bei ihnen 180 momentan und es
müsste was kosten damit sie daran
verdienen müsste 350 bis 4 Euro
verdienen müssen jemanden in Bamberg
noch zahlen kein Mensch das heißt sie
sind jetzt schon im Grunde Oberkante
Unterlippe wenn Sie das Essen teurer
machen sie verdienen vor allen Dingen am
Catering bzw an dem Essen was Sie kochen
sonntags für eine Stammkundschaft wenn
Sie das teurer machen würden da wird
keiner mehr kommen
wird keine mehr kommen weil die Leute
das Geld sitzt immer so locker wann
werden sie schließen
31.12 der letzte Tag
nach 70 Jahren die ist diesen Betrieb
dort gibt das heißt ab da werden Ihre
Kunden wo kaufen beim Discounter oder
was ist die Alternative es gibt immer
weniger Metzgereien bei uns in der um
die Ecke nur noch ein und der ist auch
ziemlich weit weg Bamberg Ost ist
eigentlich großes Gebiet ist aber dann
keine Metzgerei mehr den Grünen ist im
Grunde genommen die Energiewende
wichtiger als das Schicksal dieser ist
das so das wäre jetzt die Frage gewesen
Herr Marquardt also geht ums jetzt
polemisch zu sagen die Rostbratwurst von
den helldörfer auf ihre auf Ihr Konto
nein es ist so dass wir auf der einen
Seite eben eine und das muss man glaube
ich in solchen Diskussionen können wir
alles im Detail diskutieren aber dass
wir eine große Krise haben die nicht von
den Grünen oder der FDP oder der CDU
gemacht wurde völlig klar dass wir auf
die reagieren müssen dass wir diese 200
Milliarden hast du spät die Hand
genommen haben das war ein Fehler aus
meiner Sicht dieser Bundesregierung da
müssen sie aber vielleicht nicht bei den
Grünen schauen wer daran schuld ist dass
man so lange diskutieren musste bis man
dort unterstützen kann bis man auch
unterstützen kann dass die Energiepreise
diskutieren nicht darüber wer den Krieg
begonnen hat das ist die Sache die klar
ist Putin hat den Kriegen die Frage ist
ob wir darauf richtig reagiert haben
Bundesregierung reagieren müssen dass
das nicht passiert ist liegt aber nicht
an den Grünen aber die Energiekrise das
muss man schon sagen wir können nicht
alles auf Putin schieben nicht die
Energiepreise stiegen schon in 21 an
warum weil die europäische Politik sie
Systeme Europaparlament gesagt hat wir
wollen einen Kampf gegen Kohle Öl und
Gas führen es wurde der
Verbrennungsmotor verboten 35 da haben
die Grünen sich jetzt richtig kräftiger
jubeln sie ja
steigen und das ist steigen aus etwas
ist unser Problem ja wir reißen unser
Haus aus haben wir das neue noch gar
nicht gebaut und wenn vorstellen dass
sie diese Energie die zur Mobilität
nötig ist durch Strom ersetzen der durch
welchen Strom der bitteschön da ist dann
auch noch die Kernenergie Weg die Kohle
will man hier auch nicht haben anstatt
sich wirklich mal ohne ideologisch an
die Sache zu gehen wir können
Kohlekraftwerke machen in Brandenburg
schon mal gezeigt worden in Spremberg
Kohlekraftwerke mit CO2-Abscheidung also
grüne Kohlekraftwerke das wäre die erste
Möglichkeit sagen wir lassen die
Kohlekraftwerke wir habe ich ja jetzt
macht wir lassen weiterlaufen aber dann
brauchen wir oben eine Abscheidung da
sind sie auch klimaneutral will man aber
nicht ist Deutschland verboten
Fracking ist verboten aber auch die
Abscheidung von CO2 ist Verbot das
nächste ist Erdgas muss man machen und
das drittes Laufzeitverlängerung und das
ist alles von Europa schon vorher
eingetütet worden die
Emissionszertifikate haben den Strom in
Deutschland bei Gas verdoppelt bei Kohle
verdreifacht das heißt seine Verdopplung
ist schon passiert da waren die Russen
noch gar nicht da ja das ist Männer
passiert das kann man in den Statistiken
sehen und wir müssen uns ehrlich machen
es ist vieles selbst vor uns verursacht
indem wir eine Politik gemacht haben wie
gesagt wir wollen raus aus dem CO2 da
kann man ja
sich sehr für sehr sehr verständigen
aber doch bitte nicht in zehn Jahren
aber darum gehen politisch geworden die
wir sind zu schnell zu hastig und
zerstören etwas während wir das andere
noch nicht aufgebaut